let's button this thing up shall we
let's bring our boy chris sims our new
teammate our quarterback chris sims into
the car what's up doug how you doing
what's up michaels mike goals i should
say i'm doing good man thanks for having
me
good now appreciate you listen you know
who's not doing well unfortunately
through no fault of his own to rod
taylor i gotta start with that story oh
um because as you know wow the idea that
you cannot lose your job to injury
that's whoever said that is just
completely wrong happens all the time
however this is unusual for those that
haven't been keeping track
crack ribs painkiller injection before
the game went horribly wrong punctured
along that's why it was a late scratch
justin herbert sixth overall pick looked
fantastic they're sticking with her for
health reasons hard to believe that
anthony linden organization would go
back from herbert but that's that's i
hate to use this word because life ain't
fair but that's real unfair any chris
sims
i mean it's about as unfair as it gets
it really is i mean first off i really
do feel bad for tyrod taylor i mean it
was two years ago right when he's
playing for the cleveland browns hurts
his wrists and the same story happens
baker mayfield comes in and we go whoa
he looks kind of good i know he's a
rookie but let's start playing him you
know then got supplanted in buffalo when
he went to the playoffs so he's been
very unlucky underappreciated all those
types of things and this is one where
i don't even know how to explain it you
know that's a tricky area there in the
ribs he wants to play he's tough i'm
sure the the doctor who i don't think is
intentionally trying to hurt him i mean
he's a good guy
he's just trying to get it in there to
where tyrod can throw and feel
comfortable but obviously that didn't
happen and now you've got the carolina
panthers versus the chargers this
weekend and herbert as you mentioned
looked really good last week he's got
the highest ceiling guys out of all the
quarterbacks that came out in this last
draft he's got some freakish ability as
you saw and carolina's defense is not
that good i would expect him to play
pretty well and then the owner and gm
step into the situation and go wait we
drafted this guy number six he looks
pretty good let's start the future and
start going there
well i want to ask about that comment
about herbert having the highest ceiling
but before i get there
just a game game situation anthony lynn
defended himself
uh giving it up on fourth and one wanted
to give his team another opportunity
what did you think i feel like if you
got to play kansas city you got to be
aggressive and go for it how did you see
it
yeah that's one of those there and i'm
not always for the aggressive move go
for the aggressive move but when you
play kansas city this is where analytics
are different you know this is it's not
it's not always you know oh the numbers
say do this and i'll do it now you got
to take into account what's on the other
side of the field do the analytics like
can do they have a formula that can say
whoa this is the clutches guy in
football on the other side and he can
make magic happen uh no probably not now
the thing that anthony lynn i think
probably saw is he went kansas city
struggled moving the ball against us all
day long i think my defense can make one
more stop but as we've seen you just you
don't do that against patrick mahomes so
no i did not totally agree with that
decision i probably would have gone for
it you're right push the issue um i'm
sick of analytics all over football
though i can tell you that much
that's funny you know you mentioned that
herbert has the highest ceiling
and i'm thinking about tua tango viloa i
love that pick from miami i loved him in
college and he used to get banged up a
lot and i guess that's not a good thing
for a quarterback you tell me
but i would say it's him why would you
pick herbert over to her
was definitely the most game ready ready
to go i mean i made him my number one
quarterback in this class but herbert
had things you saw in the evaluation
process where you went like whoa look at
this big dude running down the sideline
running away from dbs i mean last week
he ran over a linebacker and concussed
him and then he has an arm that truly is
special i mean i know you guys saw some
of the game last week he made a few
throws in that game where i think the
kansas city defenders were like whoa i
can't believe you got that in there we
thought only our guy or like an aaron
rodgers could do that so he came from
oregon it was a really basic raw offense
and it wasn't pretty so he's got room to
grow that way tua on the other hand mr
holly all right i was not the biggest
fan of him coming out he was my third
rated quarterback i like him don't get
me wrong but you mentioned it size
issues overrated athleticism he's good
in the pocket and can bounce around but
made very few nfl throws when people
were around him and i would like to just
you know also say he had you know
two offensive first-round tackles four
first-round wide receivers an
unbelievable offense and that offense
didn't miss a beat really when he came
out so i think he was a little bit more
overrated in my opinion holly and just
the fact that i think he was a piece and
a great machine which is alabama i'm not
sure how great tool will be as a pro
we'll see i'll bet you a burger on it or
something
okay
so you know what tua we don't expect him
to play because he's not starting yet
right i want to talk to you about my
jacksonville jaguars
all right that's my squad and
that's the nerd in me talking that is
the the general manager that i've always
wanted to be that's my dream
talking with the team that's got 11
draft picks
in this year's draft after having i
think 10 or whatever in the last draft
that dismantled it because that's how i
would have done it out of liquidated the
roster right but then you turn around
and you know this isn't a plan you win
week one against houston thankfully they
had a moral victory because that's what
i'm about is moral victories with this
team because i was
i was
tanking for trevor
but i'll be damned if gardner-menchie
don't look like the truth so if you're
the jacksonville ja are you a believer
in gardener minshew is he the
quarterback and now you got the best of
both worlds you already got your
quarterback now you can take those two
first rounds and the rest of those draft
picks and build the rest of your team
how do you see that that franchise's
future at the qb position well i think
it could yeah i think you explained it
pretty well i mean i am i am a believer
in gardner mentioned there's no doubt
about it i mean he's got everything you
want as an nfl starting quarterback you
know moxie charisma
uh playmaking ability when the offense
doesn't deliver somebody open he has a
great ability to kind of move around the
pocket dance get out of the pocket make
a play that way when there are plays
there to be had he doesn't miss it he
takes advantage of all that's there so
i'm with you and yeah they're kind of
rebuilding on the fly there's a lot of
young talented guys on that team right
now that i like and if this continues
what we saw
i know they're one and one
they didn't really deserve to beat the
colts week one but
you know regardless they've looked very
good in both games where you go well
they're better than i thought if he
continues to play like this then yeah
sorry it's uh they got to move on from
the trevor lawrence conversation
and start just building around
gardner-minchu and build the team to be
the best team possible you don't always
need the greatest quarterback in the
history of the planet to win football
games go to the playoffs and win a super
bowl we discussed that a little this
past last week right i mean hey phil
sims had the giants and the giants d he
won a super bowl because of that in a
running game and he made some throws dan
marino didn't get that so he got zero
super bowls and uh it's about the team
and i think we've lost sight of that now
in the nfl it's all about one guy
constantly
well you mentioned phil sims and i know
one thing
phil sims knows about is he knows about
bill belichick and bill belichick
fashion he knows about bill belichick
quirks
so does chris sims
um he did not look good yesterday chris
i just got to tell you i don't know what
was going on
but you've been around and michael smith
said it yesterday he said you know bill
belichick just gives zero f's about
anything he just doesn't he just doesn't
care hey here it is this is who i am
take it or leave it you leave it i don't
care
uh i'm sure you've seen i'm sure you've
seen and women oh yeah that side of bill
belichick give us some of your
observations over the years of bill just
kind of doing his own thing
well yeah he does his own thing he gives
zero fs as what michael smith is saying
there's no doubt about that i mean it
he's past the point of trying to be
charismatic you know with the media or
anything like that it's a far cry from
his days when he was like the coach of
the jets for one day right you go back
and watch that and now he's won six
super bowls and he's like i can wear
anything to a press conference it
doesn't matter but he's the ultimate
curmudgeon guys he really is i mean if
you made me bet
they got off the plane from seattle and
that coaching staff went right to the
office never went home didn't sleep he
probably slept at the office that next
night and he just said the hell was
doing my hair or trying to look good for
a press conference that's not gonna
happen guys he's the kind of guy that's
so deep in thought and so in another
world i always say like if he was on
wall street he'd be running wall street
he'd be the wolf but
like i would walk by him when i worked
worked there guys and it would be me and
him alone gone down a hallway at nine
o'clock at night and i'd be a little
nervous because i'm like oh gosh here
comes coach belichick and he'd be kind
of walking and thinking and i would be
hey coach and he would look up and he
was like he had no idea i was walking
there next to him he was so deep in
thought thinking about game plan and
what he was going to do and it was kind
of like oh hey chris like i didn't even
see you there but that's the way he is
and yeah you're right he doesn't care
about anything else except winning and
that football team
so for my last thing for you chris can't
let you go without talking about the
game of the week maybe the game of the
year it may not be the best game and
it's very early in the season week three
to be called the game of the year who
knows what happens but i think it it's
the the highest stakes game of the year
the patriots will be there at the end as
bill likes to say i think two other
organizations that you know are going to
be at the end of this especially if the
quarterbacks stay healthy kansas city
and baltimore
um who do you like in that game and i
feel like it'll come back to bite the
loser in terms of home field in the afc
title game or just in the playoffs in
general what do you like
yeah i mean especially going to come
back to bite them in the butt on this
year when you only get one team that
gets that first round bye right because
of the new playoff format so it's it's
even more important um i always went
into this the last few years going
kansas city matches up really well with
the baltimore ravens steve spagnuolo the
things he'll do on defense he's so smart
he's creative kansas city does have some
big people in the middle of their
defense to where i always felt like they
can slow down that lamar jackson high
octane run attack and then with
baltimore being so aggressive on the
defensive side and marcus peters and
marlon humphrey in your face and we're
gonna play bump and run and blitz i
always thought that played into the
hands of mahomes and the chiefs
but
there's a little bit of a difference
this year and i'm riding with the ravens
in this one and i wouldn't have last
year the ravens i think the big thing is
this lamar jackson good thing they
didn't move him to receiver okay that's
what i'm gonna say because he is right
he is the man i don't he's almost you
know unstoppable at this point with his
ability to run and we continue to see
the polish as a passer and him making
plays that way and now they have the
emergence of the hollywood brown and a
few other receivers that are dependable
in the past game
i don't see how kansas city beats
baltimore on on uh monday night not with
caleus campbell and marcus peters on the
on on the team now and some other young
linebackers who are impressive i think
baltimore's you know closed that gap and
it is better than kansas city
and michael holly places his bet right
now thank you very much
chris sims i'm taking your word for it i
appreciate you man always good to see
you and by the way
let's not bet a burger let's bet a steak
i need okay
i'm down for that yep okay good steak
i'll take that thanks for having me guys
i'll see you next week i hope i think i
might be coming back appreciate you bro
absolutely yeah
regular let's make this a regular thing
brother appreciate you all right hang on
get you on the three-way next week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports